[Music]
very strange story very disturbing story
I wanted to mention in Ohio a man was
arrested after a neighbor spotted him
having sex with a pink inflatable pool
raft yeah just having sex
see there's this story yes I'm not
making this up and I was watching this
sort of like he's got to be a real sick
perv to have sex with an inflatable raft
you have a really sick mind - what was
that
Ellen why did you just cut to that guy
sorry Conan that was just a camera
miscue my fault okay I'm really sorry
that was awful I'm apologize that was an
accident all right as I was saying this
creep in Ohio had sex in public
with a pool raft he took out the raft
yes Oh what the hell I'm really sorry
Conan the booth is having some major
technical issues well tell the booth to
get it together okay I'll tell the
breakdow Kotov thank you
all right I'm very sorry that's awful
it's not gonna happen again
hey everybody kept an [ __ ] down there
is throwing another one of his hissy
fits so let's keep it tight
Allen I can hear you sorry I forgot to
turn my mic off whatever fine anyway
let's just get back on track the story
you have to imagine this guy it's
incredible he and he's inflating a pool
raft he's taking off his clothes
Allen stop cutting of that guy and that
more important what the hell was that
noise about the noise was just me
cleaning my glasses without my glasses
on camera two looks a lot like camera
three and I accidentally cut to the guy
again don't do that again okay all right
anyway the story gets weirder it turns
out this isn't the first time that he's
been arrested for having sex with a
plastic wrap one should go plastic the
sex is fantastic
okay all right now okay I want to know
why we cut to that guy again but Andy
why did I hear your voice I you know
what that is a voiceover for a
commercial that I recorded earlier for
breast implants audio must have got
mixed up I don't know all right well
let's just try and pull it together here
okay and let's just get back to the raft
pervert
okay leave this guy alone it just makes
you wonder what could possibly going on
inside that guy's head what's he
thinking let's go
[Applause]
I don't even want to hear an explanation
about why that videotape appeared in a
thought bubble above that guy's head I
am really sorry sir I'm very sorry
you've been a really good sport you've
been very patient and you have my word
okay we will not embarrass you any
further
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
as
Pech hey that guy is slowly getting
interested
all right let's move on ladies and
gentlemen we have quite a show tonight
[Applause]
please go
[Music]
[Applause]
I like even he's laughing
[Applause]